it's great to welcome to the program
today Jerry Mitchell whose stories have
helped put four Klansmen and a serial
killer behind bars there's that's an
introduction aching for more detail
Jerry so I appreciate the opportunity to
talk to you so tell us a little bit
about your investigative work and you
you wrote the book race against time
which tells the story of Ku Klux Klan
murders that went unpunished during the
civil rights movement talk a little bit
about how you got into this space and
how this all developed things happen
pretty close proximity
the first being I happen to see the
movie Mississippi Burning which is a
fictional film about the killings of the
three young men the civil rights workers
killed at a Klan in Mississippi James
Chaney and you given into making shorter
and they were killed on the first day of
summer in 1964 which was also part of
Freedom Summer which was very important
to the civil rights movement in terms of
college students coming down and give it
to one of those uh but they're basically
nobody
the thing is shot I mean watching a film
and I happen to be sitting by the FBI
agent by the way who investigated the
case which was another wild thing in
retrospect but I was shocked to discover
more than 20 Klansmen of all that
killing and nobody ever been prosecuted
for murder that was the part I just
couldn't wrap my head around
David artists was that common I mean in
there going back however far back you
want to go how common was it that the
perpetrator was in lynchings etc were
just never prosecuted extremely common
but I was woefully ignorant and I at the
time in 1989 and so you know I grew up
on my little you know white bread world
and East Texas and I didn't know any of
this you know and so here I had plucked
in Mississippi in this new job and
anyway it's all news
me and I'm just a lowly reporter and
just you know stumble across this and so
I started reporting about that and about
the same time I find out about this I
don't know if you're like me but if
someone tells me I can't have something
I want it like a million times worse
right so there was something Mississippi
called the Mississippi sovereignty which
was the state segregation spy agency and
there were like a hundred thirty-two
thousand pages of records that the
Mississippi legislature sealed for 50
years one of them so when I found that
out my first thought was well there's
something in there you know don't be
stealing for 50 years otherwise so I had
developed sources to begin to leave me
the files and what they showed was at
the same time the state of Mississippi
was prosecuted Barney little Beckwith
for murdering Megara versus other Norman
states sovereignty Commission was
secretly assisting the defense trying to
get back with acquitted and nobody knew
that and so my story ran October 1st 89
and that's you know basically the case
gallery oh that's kind of the short and
when it comes to I mean so there's a few
cases that you've worked on so-called
cold cases that you've started
researching on and researching and
reporting on at what point during these
what is the step that makes it so that
it is officially reopened and being
reinvestigated that kind of opens the
door once again right well the case of
the major case it was this revelation
and helped to pry open by the end it
kind of one thing led to another Myrlie
Evers asked for the case be reopened the
newspaper the Clarion Ledger where I was
working editorial lines for the City
Council voted for it and basically the
DA's office by the end of the month said
he was reopening the case but it really
didn't kind of tie begin to turn until
months later when discovery of that
Beckwith had bragged to a Klansman about
killing Medgar Evers and so that kind of
began to turn the tide it was
technically Rio
but didn't what's gonna happen and
that's really so when you start
investigating some of these cases what
type of investigative work are you doing
are you are you saying who can I talk to
are you interviewing witnesses is it a
lot of data and research work yeah we're
like for example I was able to get a
copy of the transcript
Myrlie Evers had shared and widowed
Medgar Evers and so that was really
helpful I went and interviewed the
police officers for example that gave
back with an alibi and they their story
differed from what they one of them
differed from what he had told back in
64 in the trials now those officers even
agree to talk to you years ago for my
Herald pretty much white or lighter he
said well I look like Opie you know so I
mean I think I came across this kind of
a horrible sky you know in their eyes
it's certainly southern so anyway
welcome and at different points as these
cases start to shift from being unlikely
to ever you know having a resolution to
hey we're this is being looked into -
hey there there could be charges coming
do you worry about your personal safety
[Music]
you know she was here I'm going to
interview the killer of mega rivers and
she was eight months pregnant with her
son so yeah you know I didn't take it
really into account but but speaking of
Beckwith I went in the interview and and
so yeah there were some frightening
moments I when I when I interviewed
Beckwith I spent about six hours with
him absolutely this most racist person
ever spent time with and it was six
hours later
it's dark he insist on walking me out to
the car and I'm like really that's okay
for the car he says if you write
positive things about white Caucasian
Christians God will bless you if you
write negative things about why
Caucasian Christians God will punish you
if God does not punish you directly
several individuals will do it for him
right I was going to say if it was just
going to be left to God that's one thing
but he's making it clear that that may
be yeah so I mean I have so many
different aspects of things that I want
to ask about but in in your
investigation in some of these
conversations you know one of the
interesting things that at least today
is not often told about the history of
the civil rights movement the
Mississippi Burning cases it is an
interesting example is that there were a
lot of Jewish folks who were working
with the civil rights movement and in
fact sometimes the victims including in
Mississippi Burning are presumed to be
black Americans but are Jewish folks did
you in your work on these cases also
encounter that anti-semitism was just
completely wrapped up with the anti
black racism he was really almost really
more any semitic than he was
any black anything that wasn't white
pretty much but he was a part of what's
called christian identity and he Beck
was is not alone on that the head of the
Klan was also believed this and
Christian identity is essentially just a
horrible racist you know religion and
they believe that Adney for white people
they believe that all the other
non-white races are mud people
quote-unquote they're like animals and
I'm Souls and and then they believe I
mean this is where it gets really ranked
and horribly racist toward the Jews they
believe the Jews are literal offspring
of Satan right no you know what's
interesting about hearing you say mud
people I think it was more than
years ago I interviewed this guy named
Glenn Miller who says since has been
arrested of course for killing people he
believed were Jewish but in fact were
not and I asked him uh you know in from
your perspective is is the real threat
the black folks or the Jewish folks and
it was sort of like hard for him to even
say like there was just a lot of it's
not even clear he had it straight but
they were all mud people that's the
exact word that he used as their common
this is a common term of Christian
identity and that's what they believe
it's you know they believe that white
people are the true Israelites it just
gets very strange and you know I mean
following the logic of it there's not
really logic but yes you are correct
they believe mud people and and very
anti-semitic I mean there's a really
good book on there's several good books
we could point to but blood in the face
James Ridgeway Road which talks about in
fact they brought that term up to me
that's why they believe it's white
people because white people can blush
and then and then there's a book Jack
Nelson wrote some years ago called
terror in the night which is about
basically the Klan in Mississippi were
originally attacking African Americans
as well as white sympathizers but then
they really shifted their focus to
attacking the Jews I began to bomb
synagogues Bob Jewish leaders homes and
things like that for any of the Klansmen
blindsided by charges in other words was
while you were working on stuff did
people start to get a catch wind of what
was going on in creasing Lee nervous
okay and or stop talking to me at
certain points you know because my idea
was to get in there early I wanted to
talk to the killers I wanted to hear
what they had to say and keep them
talking it and they're just because just
at certain points I know we had actually
because Beckwith
talking to me but we had another
reporter who went and actually was
sitting there almost right right when
Beckwith he got a call that basically he
was gonna get arrested and he was like
they sent a reporter away and back with
us and Beckwith and his wife or fuming
and yeah so it's fascinating you know to
hear all this as it unfolds I think that
there will be people who listen to our
conversation and they will maybe
envision that the era you were
investigating was a different era where
things you know people don't get away
with murder in the same way now that
they did then but in fact in some parts
of the country the murder resolution
rate is actually quite low and there's a
lot of good research about this there's
you know some more specific ideas about
vehicular homicide being a pretty safe
way to kill someone if you want to
murder them that's kind of a more niche
topic but generally speaking it's not
like murders are overwhelmingly being
solved today is it you know smart you
know
look carried out by people who you know
maybe they're angry at the time and you
know their hands yes what I'm saying is
most homicides are relatively easy to
solve you know I mean but you're right
about the murder resolution right in
terms of the ones that are better that
are different more difficult to solve
you're right the raid is not what you
would love to like to see because in
other words like if you have any
intelligence about it it's almost easier
to get away with murder if that makes
any sense they're going to uh we're
gonna go to a break on the broadcast
show but we're gonna continue our
conversation with Jerry Mitchell which
you can find in full over over on our
youtube channel so can you talk a little
bit about I mean you you mentioned at
the beginning and explaining some of
these cases that part of what was going
on was that authorities were actually
assisting the defense in other words
there there was what we would call a
foul play from from from authorities can
you talk about how that played into your
investigation in terms of whether law
enforcement was stonewalling you yeah
that's what you saw these cases I mean
the makers case is a great example you
had three different police officers who
gave Byron de la Beckwith an alibi like
clean that he couldn't have killed
Medgar Evers the basis line this is
beyond they lied they claimed he was you
know you know our two way or ninety
miles away in Greenwood Mississippi so I
mean at the time and they they gave no
explanation for why they would have
remembered it and remember this is a
small town these were small town police
officers and they would have seen
hundreds of people a day they that they
knew and why would you remember this
because Beckwith wasn't the thing that
people forget is Beckwith wasn't
arrested for another ten days so it's
not like they would they would have it
they didn't connect him they say he was
doing something unusual
then connect the time to anything it was
very obvious they were lying and they
were and they were incredibly specific
in the time it's like 105 they claim
this song at one of the five it's like
it couldn't even tell I mean he was
something more memorable which was when
they heard on the radio that Medgar
Evers was killed they couldn't give a
definite time for that you know what I
mean so it's pretty obvious and then in
the Mississippi Burning case you had law
enforcement who actually helped carry
out the crime and basically what
happened is Cecil price was the deputy
arrested the three civil rights workers
James Chaney who is not going to be
african-american
who's the native Mississippian you had
Mickey Schwerner and Andy Goodman both
from New York and both were the
involvement civil rights movement but
Mickey for longer and make it was
involved and his wife Rita involved a
number of protests before this and so
anyway they basically locked him up in
jail
false charges and then release them into
the hands of the waiting Klansmen who
guys then first took them out and
summarily executed them in buried the
bodies 40 yeah about 15 feet down and
they weren't around for 44 days so have
you ever been in the cases you've
researched have the participants the
enablers in in positions of authority
been held accountable at all these three
police officers in the mega rivers case
they were never charged with perjury or
you know anything like that one of them
did testify in the trial which took
place in 1994 but it wasn't like he got
prosecuted for perjury so no I would say
for the most part you didn't see law
enforcement held held responsible the
the sheriff and in Mississippi Bernie
case he was actually the only trial he
had was a federal trial and he was
acquitted on federal charges because he
was off you know put you know off in
Meridian his wife was having surgery or
something like that so he's supposedly
away at the time which of course none of
that would have happened without his
permission and he allegedly met the
Klansmen after they got done and said if
any of you talk I'll kill you in terms
of documents so you were doing a lot of
really I think all of this before the
age of FOIA Freedom of Information Act
requests and you talked a little bit
about documents that were leaked to you
were provided to you but generally
speaking like what was your process for
finding documentary evidence reporters
the way you work is you try to figure
out what law enforcement record still
exists or a court record still exists so
obviously go to the court go to clerk's
office go to the court file like the
transcript you know they ended up
pieces ended up being all over the place
in the maker evers case for example
Myrlie Evers had to copy of the
transcript that that wasn't in a court
file he had the prosecutor case which
this part sounds like I'm making it up a
prosecutor in the case had found the
murder weapon in his father-in-law's
closet and the and the Jackson Police
were cleaning out a closet and found a
box that contained the crime scene
photographs of killing America Evers
including the fingerprint of Byron de la
Beckwith lifted from the murder weapon
so there are all these things you're
essentially everyone's kind of casting
out and trying to find stuff I know I
got like I said it when interviewed
Beckwith I found lots of old newspaper
articles Madan during these days we used
microfilm and so you would like go on to
microfilm and look at old newspaper
stories for example and see okay what
got reported at the time who were some
of the witnesses at the time and then
try and track those down and that's how
I found those police officers was
essentially I will tell one story this
is obviously all pretty internet so we
used to have in the newsroom we've got
stacks of phone books you know because
like we were statewide newspapers so we
covered the whole state it's clearing
later so ahead so anyway I talked to the
one police officer and he didn't know
where the other police officer was holly
was this guy's name other guy he was and
Chris what was the guys trend fun
Hollis Chris was a name so anyway I had
the phone book and look he had a real
unusual last name Kressel with one s and
so I looked in the phone book and there
were like about a half dozen or less
than that of thing so I just picked the
name that look most promising and called
and just did my did my best southern
accent you know and I was like is Hollis
there you want my cousin he lives over
and made let me give you the note
you know typical southern thing you know
a different airlock for sure yeah that's
amazing that's an incredible story
Jerry Mitchell wrote the book race
against time where he tells the story of
KKK murders that went unpunished during
the civil rights movement until decades
later prosecutions took place in great
part thanks to Jerry's investigative
reporting up Jerry I so appreciate your
time today and really really appreciate
your work as well thanks very much for
having to appreciate